you love injurious with a reckless self
abandon
[Music]
[Music]
all right we are live now
hello world my name is Dan Cavazos Dhin
and I am joined by my co-host over to my
right is it you're right you're right
yes yes I guess I guess I don't know how
are you doing just fine and I don't
change it now and 94 there they're
flat-out spider-man podcast for a long
time and on and then maybe you know
maybe on this world they're also on
their show so yeah yeah and we're we're
hearing an echo right now which means I
got to figure that out really quickly so
everybody bear with us for a second as
we get the tech kind of figured out so
Xavier and Mark are you hearing an echo
from me and you guys I am hearing an
echo from you so let me figure out what
is going on
gotta love strenght lobstery gotta love
streaming we're gonna go live the show
will start in about four minutes so I
apologize yeah about about this we
haven't had an echo before so we're
gonna figure this out both of you are
you guys fully on your headsets correct
okay no no external audio all right why
are we getting an echo all right can you
guys speak for me for a second Rumble
and mumble and stutter until which
hasn't happened yet so keep talking I I
know I know what it is I think I have it
fixed now can you guys both speak for me
all right cool I'll go next hey Dan did
you get it fixed or what I believe it's
fixed Xavier should we do that improv
thing where I just say one word and then
he says another word and then we build a
story out of it there we go we got it we
got it fixed so all right before the
show goes live yeah those who are
listening this on the Amazing Spider
Talk YouTube channel
you know Xavier is a really amazing you
know video essayist on YouTube is that
how you would describe yourself Xavier a
little bit of just just flat-out reviews
I also do cosplay tutorials so if you
ever want to learn how to sew a
spider-man costume from scratch I can
teach you
and occasionally streaming a lot of
stuff but usually in the realm of comics
absolutely so like one of the one of the
reasons I wanted to bring you on the
show Xavier and we could talk about this
when the show gets started is that you
know you do a lot of great videos on
animated shows a lot of them being
spider-man shows there's been an ongoing
joke on your channel that you're not a
spider-man Channel and here we are
proving it wrong again but yeah because
what that whole thing was that like I
got kind of my start doing this big
retrospective look back at review series
of all the spider-man videogames and
like that just kind of hit some kind of
hidden Miche around the time and like
got a lot of attention and I've just got
nothing but requests to do more
spider-man content ever since then even
though I just like general comic book
things so I've always been like well I'm
I'm not explicitly just a spider-man
channel but like anytime I do talk about
him everyone always kind of harasses me
about it in a weird way because they're
always bringing back that not a
spider-man Channel quote to kind of to
poke fun at me but I don't mind it it's
it's funny it's all I'm good it's all in
jest well very cool very cool
for those who are in the chat hang out
after the show I mean this is a podcast
that does a live show portion so you're
gonna be maybe a little bit confused to
get started but it will all make sense I
promise after the show we're gonna be
answering your questions from the chat
so hang around to the show's completed
and you know you can hang out with us
for a little bit of a live stream
hangout and we'll answer your questions
about comics about animated series we're
really excited about that so you know
you guys ready should we get the show
started but Dan except for Bob Dole
we're not answering his questions right
we don't want the Bob Dole guy chiming
in so is everybody ready to go Xavier
mark oh yeah I suppose so all right here
we go let's have a showdown let's get
the show started
[Music]
every time I open a comic book and read
from panel to panel it allows for my
imagination to filling the gutter with
spectacular movement that transforms
simple lines and colors into vivid
playgrounds for my imagination with a
character like spider-man
that means imagining him flipping around
New York City street corners on a web
landing a sweet sucker punch on a
snarling villain and helping his frail
Aunt May cross the street in translating
spider-man to early animation no longer
do we have to imagine these movements
anymore in the late 60s spider-man burst
onto television screens and bright
colors with a catchy theme song but
admittedly limited animations in the
1970s he squared off against corporate
villains and high rises in live-action
but it wasn't until the early 80s that
we began to see his true potential on
the small screen and animated shows like
1981 spider-man and its sequel
spider-man and his amazing friends
hello I'm dapper dank of Austin and I
own every issue of Amazing Spiderman
including the annuals which I think
definitely count and I'm mischievous
marcin Akio and I own every issue of
Amazing Spiderman including the annuals
but the annuals don't count welcome to
the fourth season of The Amazing Spider
Talk the show where two fans and
collectors uncover the strange fun and
fascinating history of the Spider Man
comic universe if you want to swing
along with us on our journey through
Spidey's past president future subscribe
to amazing spider talk on your favorite
podcast app every other week we put out
a main line episode of our flagship show
and sprinkled in between we review new
comics as well as interview some of the
greatest spider-man creators of
yesterday and today this is the perfect
time to start listening and Dan we even
have new comics coming up now I know the
world is alive again in this season of
the all-new Amazing Spider talk we'll be
revisiting spider-man's adventures in
the early 80s where denim jackets were
hip the villains were forgettable and
the creative voices of Marvel were
constantly changing sure spider-man
comics weren't at their
creative zenith but seemingly nothing
could stop spider-man's meteoric rise
through the pop culture landscape part
of the ascension came in the form of two
new cartoon shows that sought to build
off the foundations laid by the popular
1960s show so that's exactly where we're
going what we're gonna be talking about
today
1981 spider-man and the follow up series
spider-man and his amazing friends and
if you haven't already check out that
awesome artwork commissioned from Nick
Cagney depicting spider-man Iceman and
Firestar fighting against Doctor Doom
it's great because it's actually a
recreation of the legendary John Romita
Jr is Network pitch artwork for
spider-man and his amazing friends
that's right mark and if you're watching
live you know what Mark's talking about
because you're looking at it right now
because we're also video streaming our
show live every other Sunday at 8:30
p.m. Eastern Time tune in on YouTube as
we talk and record amazing spider talk
live Plus mark and I are gonna stick
around after the show to interact the
audience and answer your questions live
just go to amazing spider talk on
YouTube hit subscribe and be sure to
turn on the notifications by clicking on
that little bell to be reminded when
they go live but we couldn't do this
alone I mean we couldn't but no way
today we are bringing no instead we're
bringing in one of our very own amazing
friends to help us discuss these shows
Dan it's great that we get to kind of
pop the live cherry with an amazing
friend with on the amazing friends
episode right yeah absolutely it makes
perfect sense okay yes so that amazing
friend of course is none other than
YouTube's own Xavier Mendoza from the
grid's illa Mendoza Channel welcome to
the show Xavier hey it's nice to be here
and I'm really honored to both be on the
show on your guys's end and then help
you know stream it on my channel for
those who don't know about me I'm some
dorky kid from the US who loves to
cosplay write stories and read comics on
my own channel i review comics games and
animated shows as well as do cosplay
tutorials so if you ever want to learn
how to sew spider-man costumes from
scratch I can teach you how to do that
I've also reviewed all of spider-man's
videogames and just a lot of other comic
book II stuff whatever just strikes my
fancy at the time so uh hi well welcome
to the show Xavier I'm curious you know
everybody's got an origin story in terms
of spider-man like what was the first
experience you really had with the
character
I actually remember it pretty vividly is
um when I was like 3 years old
my parents like when I was like a baby
going into a toddler they they just
bought me nothing but like Elmo stuff
all the time and like just my whole room
was entirely covered in Elmo and like
that's just what they they thought I was
like into but like I I would always go
into my dad's office in the other side
of the house and see all these Spiderman
posters all over the place and I was
like what's that who's that guy and like
he would just kind of describe it to me
as bad as well as a little kid can
understand but one day my mom was
actually taking me to store and we were
just just going around shopping and we
were in like the pharmacy aisle at a
Walmart and I was just standing up in
the shopping cart and I saw on a shelf a
spider-man action figure that I think
someone had taken to that aisle and then
just kind of left there haphazardly and
I grabbed it and was like can I have
this and she said sure so I took it home
and that spider-man action figure was
like III still have it to this day but
it's I just like kind of fell in love
with the character design and eventually
started asking my dad about like what's
his character about what are his stories
and like every time I needed new
information he would always just tell me
verbally or occasionally showed me one
of his old comics and then you know my
parents themselves have always been into
comics that's why my name is Xavier is
because my mom read a lot of x-men in
the 90s before I was born and the other
kind of funny thing about that is when
they were trying to figure out what to
name me my dad suggested Godzilla my mom
said no and was like how about Xavier
instead so that's why that ended up
being my my handle on all of the
internet stuff that's really cool I do
have to wonder though was like your your
first bedroom like all of the
interlocking covers of x-men one like as
the wallpaper or what I mean like yeah I
just have I mean nineties x-men I just
have to think actually as I started
getting older and I was like I don't
like Elmo I like I like comic books
please put spider-man stuff in my room
he decided to get all of his old comics
and just kind of like line the walls
with them like they're all uncovers with
boards and everything in plastic but he
would tack through the the plastic part
and kind of have them all like lined up
around the whole room so there was just
like Daredevils and x-men and spider-man
and even like Lethal protector venom
books and just any random day I would
just point to one and go tell me what
happens in that one and he would either
get it off the wall and show me or just
like just kind of run it down from
memory you are both like presenting me a
like better alternative version of what
my childhood could be or what some some
distant future where I have a kid and
I'm subjecting them to the same thing so
like it's cool it's cool to hear that I
think the coolest thing about comic
books as a fandom is it's very
generational it's something that gets
passed down a lot like you know we all
have a different experience with these
characters and we all have different
runs that we love but it's always cool
kind of passing down and explaining it
to someone else because like my little
sister
there's a pretty big age gap I mean
eight years older than her and she's
like just turned 13 so I'm always
explaining this stuff to her I'm like oh
yeah here's here's how venom got his
powers or I would like show her episodes
of some of the cartoons to just kind of
explain stuff quickly because listening
to me ramble about it for three hours
might not get it across as well as maybe
like a 20 minute episode well very cool
speaking of you know cartoon episodes
let's talk about the topic we're here to
talk about first up we're gonna be
talking about spider-man from 1981 and
boy I had never seen this show before
and I was so thrilled to have an
opportunity to watch this for this show
I guess I'm curious like do any of you
have a history with this show
prior to us like assigning this to watch
honestly one of my earliest memories
growing up was that my parents I think
they got it from my grandparents had an
old VHS tape that had like a bundle of
episodes from both shows that I would
just like kind of watch and re-watch
because like that was the only thing I
really had on at the time because you
know there there wasn't always you
didn't always get to choose whenever
these cartoons would come on TV but if I
wanted to watch spider-man it was
probably one of these tapes so the
episodes of black cat from the 81 series
and maybe a couple of others were
definitely ones I remember and then from
amazing friends the x-men crossover
episode was the one that I always
watched
yeah similarly I mean and this was kind
of I think I mentioned this in the last
episodes and I kind of had an
inadvertent real you know deja vu moment
with with this series specifically where
we were I was watching or we I guess now
we're watching one of the episodes it
was the one where Doctor Doom had the
the what do you call it the the bomb
under New York City and I'm like
watching this and like the dialogue from
it like all of a sudden starts coming
back to me and I'm like I had seen this
episode before where have I seen this
episode and you know dr. Google was my
friend and I remember there was a VHS
compilation of Doctor Doom episodes so
of the original 1960s Fantastic Four and
then they decided to stick this episode
on it's kind of like a bonus episode
yeah doctor do a lot out there for a
second oh I was there was a just kind of
a pause and I was thinking it was like
someone else's turn to talk might have
had that the Spidey Captain America
episode too but I couldn't figure that
out for certain but this Doctor Doom
episode is definitely on the cassette
and I just was like oh man that's that's
him that's a memory from the Wayback
Machine I also had a VHS tape with I
think I
remember vividly the amazing friends
episode with the juggernaut which we're
going to talk about in a little bit and
it probably had episodes from this show
on if Xavier memory is correct but that
was the one that really stood up my mind
so for me this was kind of like a brand
new experience of this show so let's
talk about it
spider-man from 1981 it was very
short-lived mark why don't you tell us a
little bit about the history of the show
well I guess we can go back to in 1981
Fritz Freeling is that am I saying that
name right Dan freely so yeah as my as
your guest as good as mine okay so he
left the company he founded the paddy
Freeling enterprises to resume his
former job with Warner Brothers
animation and that sparked the sale of
the company to cadence industries which
also owned Marvel Comics Group so it was
renamed Marvel productions and the
company decided to use spider-man as
kind of one of their launch programs as
a way to attract network attention to
Marvel's other properties and
potentially bring them to television you
know spider-man was always kind of the
lynchpin for you know going you know
expanding the brand of Marvel
so this depatie-freleng enterprises
their previous work with Marvel was 1978
Fantastic Four Show which is probably
best known for the fact that it did not
have a Human Torch in it yeah it said it
was Herbie Herbie or robot yeah great
great choice I guess
and then they also did a Spider Woman
show which we'll probably get into later
in the season spoiler alert when we talk
about Spider Woman in terms of you know
Marvel trying to get some branding in on
Spider Woman so they created a comic and
a animated series about that have you
guys ever seen either of those shows I
mean the Spider Woman was just added to
Disney Plus and I think it's the first
time it's been commercially available
ever and so I decided to check it out
and I checked it out and then I checked
out because I just was not interested in
it it was very strange
turned it on con out of curiosity
because I was like spider-man I'm gonna
be in this I feel like they wouldn't let
this character stand on her own she
would have to be like introduced via him
and then I was I was right and then in
the first episode he plays kind of a
part but I don't know I wasn't paying
too much attention to it there was some
weird plot about them going to Egypt and
there was magic and there was mommy as I
think so I feel like they're bad they're
bound to repeat all the mistakes the
comics made when Spiderman was first
introduced it's like what kind of
villains work with spider-man oh of
course
aliens you know and that would all be
reckoned later you know I feel like in
TV shows just repeat these kind of
strange errors over and over again until
they find their groove yeah I I never
saw the Spider Woman show but I
definitely have em Emery's of that
Fantastic Four show because I do
remember Herbie but like again this this
was probably years and years ago and I
couldn't even tell you the exact context
of how I saw that show but I've not seen
it probably since I was like 6 or 7
years old so that's that's eons ago of
people so yeah so this this shows
spider-man 1981 it first debuted
September 12th in 1981 obviously and you
know the reason a lot of people haven't
seen it is it only ran for 26 episodes
one season and you know ending March in
1982 so like it didn't have a lot of
longevity and you know it you know it
read a little bit in syndication as part
of the Marvel action universe animation
block but in the late 80s but you know
between 81 and the late 80s it didn't
run and there really wasn't much
familiarity with it but of course now
you can watch it on Disney Plus it's all
there and when you know they were
advertising it's like the lost show when
they were kind of plugging it on Disney
Plus and I think they're kind of right
about it I mean it's not been widely
viewed yeah I mean well compare it
certainly compared to amazing friends
which will I mean we'll get into the the
the logistics of that in a little bit
but like I'm
this you know when you put the two of
them side-by-side I mean they're both
they both come out on the same date but
one gets like you know the Saturday
morning network lock and then this one
was just as kind of made for syndication
and kind of languishes in that like
no-man's land forever and ever so that's
that's kind of what you know maybe
that's why there's not as much as like
nostalgia associated with this one like
everyone knows amazing friends everyone
knows Iceman because that show like
everyone even brings up Firestar even
though she hasn't really been in
anything since then substantially but
like that one just was on at the right
time and had like the right audience for
people to remember it and like make
jokes about it it can become like a pop
culture reference thing well as this
1881 cartoon is just like you know it's
it's just a weird middle child between
this or between amazing friends and the
60 he's cartoon it's funny that you say
that you bring up the pop culture meme
ability of this because it's funny
watching this through I realized that
like most a lot of the memes that I
really like from spider-man are from
this show and I always figured they were
from the 1960s show and like I mean
there's like the Spider Man wearing the
like gold helmet or spider-man laying on
the train tracks like they're all from
this there's that shame from the x-men
crossover rigs as a professor you're a
class act and does this hand sign and
stuff I yeah that that was one of the
ones that I kept seeing you always tell
just because the webs on the costume now
you're a big fan of the 90s cartoon and
I feel like one of the major like
talking you know one of the major blurbs
you hear about that show is like oh it
was subject to censorship and the
characters couldn't actually punch each
other and we've had john semper on the
show a number of times he was the
showrunner of that show and he claims
that that wasn't true and i don't know
whether you can believe that or not but
you know i'll take him at his word but
for this show it actually was true they
the characters couldn't punch each other
so they found ways around it and it
pretty much every character had laser
beams or something like that to make up
for that for that mistake
we're not mistake no creative with what
you could do with webbing yeah to make
that that combat
work yeah so mark why don't you tell us
a little bit about these like the way
the characters were designed right so
they were done by Rick Oberg and they
were actually modeled after basically
John Romita when he came on to the book
so they kind of under eyes Peter
specifically his hair his haircut the
Wardrobe was also kind of more modern
like you know oh he's always with the
turtlenecks right which was again a
Romita ism because we're meda kind of
theorized that Peter would wear a
turtleneck because it would be easier
for him to hide his costume that way
which it makes sense right I mean yeah
I've done the hide your costume under
the clothes thing that collar comes up
really high yeah I mean I'm also just
thinking about how warm a turtleneck is
but whatever I mean I sweat you know
especially when you're standing next to
fire start well we'll get there we'll
get there you know but you know it's
interesting too because the the costume
is actually like a hoodie in this show
like he brings it up and then they make
very careful the detail the like hood
going over the head and I'm not exactly
sure how that like physically works but
it's a unique design and they were very
proud of like oh yeah I think it could
work actually given a lot of the zentai
suits that I've used to make my own
Spidey costumes always have like a front
facing version of that so you kind of
pull it up and back so having it work
the other way is if you just had like
some snap buttons in the collar I think
you could pull that off yeah for sure
you know what was interesting about the
show and why people haven't seen it is
you know that halfway through the show
they basically found out that like they
couldn't secure a network to air it so
they had to kind of come up with another
alternative option and so they added a
bunch of gimmicks to the show which is
how we got amazing friends so they had
ditched the original concept half week
the season finish the season and then
rebooted the show
spider-man and his amazing friends so
they could ape off of DC's popular
Superfriends cartoon at the time and
that's kind of what brought the death to
this show is just that like people
didn't want a plain Jane spider-man show
I guess he couldn't sell enough toys
which the 1990 spider-man show would
prove disastrously wrong but yeah so
that's why the show that's kind of
languished in obscurity because it
didn't really get that treatment and I
tried to figure out why 5,000 other than
the catchiness of everyone's favorite
number 5,000 but I couldn't find
anything unless you guys can take a
guess why 5,000 it sounds cool sounds
futuristic in it it distinguishes it
from the 60s cartoon by you know just
giving it something out because both of
them are just called spider-man so I
mean maybe it has something to do with
that his his costume had that many more
lines on it
there's my guess people that's a good
guess so yeah that's that's a brief
history of the 1981 spider-man show
let's talk general thoughts about the
show we've kind of said a little bit
about it but Xavier liked watching this
through for this episode what do you
think I was actually surprised by how
well it seemed to capture like a lot of
like hallmarks of Spidey stories like
conflicts you would see in those those
types of comics around that time is like
you know Peter was out all night
fighting crime and then forgot to do his
homework so he gets in trouble at school
the next day or like he falls asleep
with his costume on and anime walks in
like a lot of like little things that
are I just consider like what makes
spider-man different from other
superheroes as these kind of minor
inconveniences in his personal life from
being a superhero and like the 60s
cartoon touched on them a little bit but
this was the one that really like went
home with it and I think that was like
really appreciated
is you could just do something like the
Japanese like live-action show or like
the Nicholas Hammond show and just
completely throw all that out and just
just give him a like a bat cave and like
have him like driving a spider mobile on
a spider plain and you know whatever toy
attic thing but they I think they
actually really cared like they seem to
get it yeah I would agree with that
wholeheartedly especially when you
compare it to other comic book based
animated shows at the time and like you
said the live-action show which kind of
went a completely different direction I
mean yes granted this is not you know I
feel we're spoiled by the spider-man 90
show and then some of the subsequent
shows in terms of the the slickness and
of the production values and kind of the
intricacies of the plots of these of
these stories I mean obviously you know
each each episode here is mostly
self-contained I mean there's like one
kind of overriding thread with Doctor
Doom kind of although like Beth Redis is
that he wants to be ruler of the world
which is you know insane of a statement
as it sounds I guess I don't know maybe
it's not but I mean but overall I feel
like this this does kind of get at the
heart of at least what Spiderman was in
the comics and and in terms of the tone
and the humor and and these little
situations that Xavier was talking about
like the little nuances and the
pratfalls of the character and and like
I don't know like I I legitimately
enjoyed watching this in its own kind of
kitschy way whereas you know when we get
to amazing friends we'll go into more
detail what that show just kind of
seemed off-the-wall to me in terms of a
concept although it's clearly the more
popular show yeah I agree with both of
you guys I think it what's great about
this show is it's very Spider Man like
it never it never feels like an I mean
well sometimes it does but mostly it
feels like it's a it's a superhero
universe and story that are uniquely
something that you would tell in a
spider-man story it's always kind of
bouncing between the supporting cast
members and Peter's life and things like
that and it's
it seems like the writers really loved
the comics they just kind of like got it
and they worked in all kinds of little
details the humor is really great and
the way that the episodes are structured
is like one of my favorite things is it
like it's always kind of balancing two
plots one that's like Peter Parker's
life and one that spider-man's life and
it you know does that classic spider-man
thing where spider-man's life ruins
whatever's going on for Peter and very
rarely does he get an a full-throated
win and to me that made it seem like
okay this is like actually actually
about spider-man and I really
appreciated that I think the sixties
show got it somewhat and maybe it's just
the voice of that show that threw me off
where but you know that big boost
booming voice but here you know Ted
Schwartz who does the voice here it's
like so on the money and I dare I say it
I think this voice is kind of like the
prototypical spider-man voice that would
kind of define the character moving
forward like everybody seems to be a
version of this well it's it's no Herbie
the elf though no it's not absolutely
sorry Xavier you do some like a lot of
voiceover stuff like had it what did you
think about the voice in this show oh
yeah I was when I went back watching it
I was expecting Dan Gill Vincent's voice
from amazing friends so I was not
expecting to hear something that sounded
different actually I would say a lot
more fitting for the 81 show like he
just there's a kind of certain there's a
softness to his voice when he's Peter
Parker that I I think is really
important that not a lot of shows
capture as he just kind of sounds a lot
more timid but like the sarcasm as a
spider-man when he like kind of the
superhero mode like he kind of does a
pretty good job of both without it being
very exaggerated like it was in the 60s
cartoon where he almost in the in that
cartoon he sounded almost like he was
trying to be like kind of cowardly as
Peter but no it's not necessarily that
more just just as sort of yeah softness
you know he he doesn't seem like a guy
you'd expect to throw punches it's very
it's actually I feel like very ramita s
square is I mean not that not that I
feel experiment 67 it's more dico but
like you know like I feel like this this
whole it's funny because you don't have
MJ and Gwen which was obviously the the
hallmark of the ramita comics but like
otherwise this feels very kind of a 60s
aesthetic in terms of the cast and the
interaction and like you said that
softness but obviously with I guess an
80s Flair I don't know I think they
wanted it to there's you know like a
certain amount of brand synergy where
they wanted it to look like what was
current so they were going for that
aesthetically well as the stories are a
little bit more classic because if
you're gonna pull from stuff might as
well go for the earlier things cuz it's
been around for a while and you know you
don't you have like a backlog of stories
to adapt or at least take inspiration
from instead of just waiting for
whatever next issue comes out I really
loved how much the show focuses on New
York itself I mean you get a lot of the
iconic things like the Statue of Liberty
and the you know the Twin Towers of the
World Trade Center which always sends me
for a spin but like to me that was like
really nice really gave it a good kind
of sense of place and the the number one
place that like I think really brings
the show to life is the offices of the
Daily Bugle we do a lot of focusing on
that and I know the 60s cartoon did but
here it feels more alive we get the
first introduction of Robbie Robertson
which from my money this is the first
on-screen appearance of Robbie Robertson
correct I would say so yeah I don't
remember him from any of the sixties
episodes granted I didn't watch all of
them but I definitely skimmed through a
pretty big portion of that show for my
my review of the of it for the
retrospective but yeah I I think this
was the first one and that may just be
kind of like a time
thing a little bit 60s having a
character like Robbie might have not I
don't know been something they were
interested in but around the 80s that
wasn't you know the times have changed
you can be progressive you can be
progressive in the pages of the comic
but not on screens what you're
suggesting yeah you know comics Roy's
like this niche thing but like the
cartoons reach a greater audience so you
know maybe maybe some older mindsets
were at play with not including him or
having him anywhere I I don't know but
that's purely speculation I mean I think
it also might have something to do with
the fact I mean I I don't disagree
Xavier but I also feel like part of it
might be the fact that I mean Jonah
himself was such a huge part of the show
I mean he was a huge part of the show in
67 but like I feel like he was just kind
of more of a punchline in 67 were here I
mean it's more of that meddlesome truck
yeah like I mean he's really like I mean
I feel like every every episode is Jonah
either you know not not literally
creating the Scorpion or the human fly
but like that level of Medellin in terms
of trying to overcome Spider Man which
is like you know kind of makes Jonah
almost the main through-line as an
antagonist in this show but beyond
Doctor Doom I would say he's almost more
of the antagonist than Doctor Doom but
um you know yeah right but well that old
that old chestnut that we always talk
about is Jonah as well he's an
antagonist was he a villain I mean you
know naming that's that whole thing I
mean it's he's a thorn in his side for
sure and then you know anyone who brings
Mortimer the nephew in it's just no good
to me Mortimer we should just rename
cousin Oliver in my opinion he is the
cousin Oliver of the spider-man animated
series yeah is what marks talking about
is there's a character Mortimer who's
Jonah's nephew that's introduced in the
show that I've never seen in any other
medium and he's barely in the show he's
probably like what four or five episodes
overall I mean he just shows up to be
like I'll do it uncle Jonah
that's that he's kind of like he's like
a dead Leeds but they wanted Betty to
date Peter so I guess they didn't want
that like triangle thing going on
because he's kind of competitive to
Peter to be like the top photographer
for the bugle right but he just can't
get those pictures to spider-man because
no one can get those pictures of
spider-man oh now and I know shout-out
to William Woodson who does the voice of
Jonah he's got I couldn't I couldn't
nail down what region of the world
accent he's got in this it's like
somewhat European it's interesting but
curiously you know this show was
competing with these seeds Super Friends
show and William Woodson did both the
narration on that show and the voice of
Jonah on this show so if this guy was
like dipping into both ponds and you
know whatever that seems only fitting
for Jonah in spite of the the kind of
all over the place accent he still just
for some reason like the tone and the
delivery he still felt like kind of what
I imagined Jonah to sound like so it
wasn't distracting honestly yeah yeah
one of the things that distracted me
though is like how spider-man's webs are
utilized in the show it's like oh yeah
it's a Green Lantern Leverett levels of
absurd like he could be like I want a
table and boom two seconds later there's
a web cable or web hammock or where he
actually makes a shovel a functioning
shovel and start scooping dirt and then
pulls just a cup out of nowhere and then
puts like some like rocks in it like the
Mars rocks that Sandman stole and then
covers it with with webs on on the lid
and I'm Hardy I have no idea how any of
this stuff came to be or how he did it
so quickly
hold on if I can make a shovel out of
twigs in Animal Crossing he can make a
shovel in this show okay actually glides
around yeah I think yeah yeah the other
thing that like drives me nuts on this
show is the musical score it's like
clear there buzz there budget like
covered maybe two songs and one of them
one of them would be like one of them is
also like it's like a variation on like
the Daisy Daisy give me your answer do
like at the beginning of every episode
like this like kind of like interlude
you know elevator stops it's not meant
to be benched because this musical score
just like drills into your brain like I
can hum it for you right now I'm gonna
spare everybody that but like it's uh
it's it's a lot and by a lot I mean it's
too little those things that works
better week to week because you're not
thinking about it as much it's like an
ear worm if the worm was a murder Hornet
[Laughter]
speaking of murder
you know the main villain mark you were
saying earlier is uh it was like kind of
dr. doom
throughout the whole season and I was
surprised by this well I mean you're
surprised by this but keep in mind it's
1981 and and Dan what is that what is
the biggest thing in pop culture in 1981
us Star Wars or The Empire Strikes Back
I mean I'm I'm surprised that we didn't
get like the Imperial March backing up
dr. doom here but that will require them
to make more music for the show and
that's not happening anytime soon and I
mean is it my imagination or like in dr.
Doom's first appearance like when I'm
like listening to this for the first I
was actually on the treadmill running
when I was watching this episode with a
hearse and I watched all these episodes
but I'm like say to myself holy crap did
they actually get James Earl Jones to do
this like it sounded so much like Vader
and then I feel like ice to show went on
they kind of like backed off that a
little bit like they gave him a little
less baritone but I was just like whoa
they are just like leaning so far into
Vader here it's nuts
there's even an episode of amazing how
much he's in this show
there's even an episode of amazing
friends where do their fighting doom and
the robots are basically like a bunch of
darth vader's with lightsabers like they
look identical to Darth Vader and they
have green glowing lightsabers that
spider-man catches at one point and
weighs around and he's like how do you
use one of these things and it's like oh
my god Star Wars has just straight-up
invaded this I mean it's all Star Wars
but then it's like everyone from
Latveria it's like basically from like
the communist bloc so like I guess
they're like you know like also leaning
into the cold war it's like it's like
boris and Natasha basically are like the
the the citizens of live area which I
thought was kind of crazy
and all of those stories are like giant
world spanning arcs like nothing can be
small with doom it's got to be master of
the universe master of the planet he
goes to the UN and like screams for
fealty I mean the show is just obsessed
with him we even get like a whole
episode about his origin and I think
spider-man's in the episode for like 30
seconds and the rest of it is just like
how did Doctor Doom become Doctor Doom
I'm not even exaggerating he's barely in
the episode yeah I mean it's also like
he's in the intro more than any other
villain in the whole show he shows up
like I think six there's seven shots of
him compared to like maybe like three or
four Green Goblin yeah it's it's it's
it's a little odd especially when you
consider the companion show to this
which you know when we talk about it oh
it doesn't
I think they feature doom once which is
kind of weird like like if he was such a
big thing why wouldn't they find a way
to use him with with amazing friends but
I mean who knows and like again like not
to I know we talked about this in the
comics and and how this kind of drives
you nuts but like again given the scope
of like some of dooms plans here like
literal world domination like and we've
already established like their crossover
episodes with Captain America with Namor
kazar know Fantastic Four but like why
wouldn't like other Marvel heroes gonna
be brought in and be like whoa whoa like
Spider Man we got your back here it's
not just you against this guy who's
literally trying who's literally taking
over like the UN is like okay you win
doom you own the world now and I'm like
wait wait wait we're like like you
telling me like cap and
iron man or just like yeah he's aw he's
all yours spell all right
we're sitting this one out what's
curious about the doom stuff is like you
know he the first episode with him is
him like going to you and and and and
like I said asking everybody to join him
or they've kind of brainwashes everybody
which sounds vaguely familiar but you
know what's cool about it is if you've
read the spider-man newspaper strip
that's kind of the first thing that he
fights in the newspaper strip is like
his first villain is doom and that exact
plot plays out is the U n think so again
like it's not so far into spider-man
like these guys were fans not just of
the comic but of the newspaper strip and
they worked that in to this so like
there is some precedents for this and
they clearly like that story because
they you see what stuff they end up
taking his inspiration because it's not
like completely random sometimes yeah it
does it does seem random like well it's
like a toy or some other thing they also
kind of bend pop-culture kind of things
like there's a lot of like arcade stuff
in amazing friends that starts popping
up but uh yeah yeah we did get some
other classic villains though like that
we would associate with spider-man like
you have lizard Kraven the hunter sad
man Mysterio kingpin vulture and Green
Goblin and I really liked the Green
Goblin episode a lot because I felt like
this one and again compared to amazing
friends kind of leans in more into the
actual comic book origin and regarding
Norman Osborn and kind of like
especially like Norman's amnesia about
Green Goblin which is cool being that
because the 60s cartoon didn't know who
Oscar was by that point so every time
you see him he has no secret identity
exactly so i i i i enjoyed least the
portrayal of that I mean you know Kraven
is kind of ridiculous in this show and
of course that's also the Khazar episode
which is just overall like bonkers but
like a lizard Sam and Mysterio I mean
like the these mostly mostly feel pretty
true again to these characters and Doc
Ock akak is the first villain kind of
similar to 67 he was the first villain
there were some new villains too dan I
know that you're fans of all them right
absolutely I did I did want to mention
that the Craven kazar episode is
interesting because it's kind of a
retelling of the Craven gaagh story down
in the Savage Land from Amazing
Spiderman what 102 so that's pretty neat
so that's cool we would never hear of we
would never hear of Gog again no but
yeah you know another thing that's
interesting to note is like the black
cat shows up in this series and like
this is like what a couple months or a
year after she was introduced in the
comics like it was like immediately from
the comics to the screen and she's fully
formed and and it's interesting about
all the villains in the show like the
main spider-man villains is they don't
really tell you their backstory except
for like Norman because I think they
kind of like expected you to have seen
the 60s show but like black hat they
give like the host makes me wonder did
they intend for that to be in continuity
with this one it seems that way in some
aspects they kind of lean there's a cop
contradictions I think somewhere around
there but like just the fact that like
Betty and Giovanna are like the only
people you know at the bugle on both
shows and like there's no other love
interest it kind of makes you wonder
yeah a hundred feels more like a sequel
for sure yeah I mean this feels more
like a sequel than amazing friends being
a sequel to this I would say yeah that
does that is very accurate for sure um
you know there were a ton of great voice
actors on the show playing these kind of
infamous characters so like the Red
Skull was voiced by Peter Cullen who did
Optimus Prime and E or the lizard
interestingly enough and I could not get
this out of my head when I was watching
the show is voiced by Corey Burton who
did Captain Hook in the Disney Peter Pan
and every time he talked that's all I
could hear was Captain Hook the vulture
is Don Messick who did the voice of
scooby-doo and bamm-bamm and a whole
other host of hanna-barbera characters
and most interestingly Neil Ross
speaking of the Goblin
he played the Green Goblin here both
Norman and the Green Goblin and he would
later reprise that role not only in
amazing friends although there he only
played the Green Goblin but in the 1994
spider-man the animated series he played
Norman and the Green Goblin again so
there's some kind of like voice
continuity across like who ever like 15
years of spider-man cartoons there's
some scenes in like a couple of
different cartoons where he's both 81
and I think that 90 show where he's
going back and forth between the Norman
and like Goblin voice like mid-sentence
and it's like really impressive how
different they sound from each other
yeah absolutely
so the Green Goblin famous villain we
all love the Green Goblin
but there's a lot of like really bizarre
new villains that are introduced in the
show such as gore on stunt man and his
triangle of evil gotta have a triangle
of evil it's better than the square of
evil
there's the Sidewinder who is this it's
hard to describe he's like a man in a
suit with like a face mask that looks
like some kind of like a kazoo monster
and a top hat and he rides around on a
Pegasus with like a group of bandits who
also have Pegasus and they I believe
they joust spider-man at some point I
don't know what is up with this design
but Sidewinder so I'm just getting over
the fact that you just pluralized
Pegasus is it pegasi
proceed and proceed I'm sorry yeah
Sidewinder he would never reappear again
and I think for good reason
there's the gadget tier he's like this
like purple dressed balding I say that
fondly as a bald man himself
balding like janitor who decides to like
get in like a purple onesie with like a
face mask and Rob everybody I don't know
why it wasn't just the tinkerer but okay
the gadgets here there's professor gizmo
and then there's Neffe Leah who is this
like
he once spider-man's powers but he ends
up turning himself into a man spider
which like I guess this the first
appearance of a man spider and then
because they couldn't use the burglar
they brought in you know the burglar
that kill Uncle Ben they brought in the
burglars cousin witch
fine great and yet even they couldn't
reveal Mortimer as a villain which just
really upsets me but anymore makes me
wonder if like the reason for all the
original villains like much like the 60s
cartoon is did they have to because like
these days it's usually like the
character rights are kind of bundled
together you know you just you get
spider-man you get his villains but back
then I feel like it was more of like a
case-by-case basis so they had to
purchase the license for every
individual character or something like
and maybe it was just easier to
sometimes throw in some random just
something like a guy riding a Pegasus
just to just to fill for an episode
because they couldn't afford someone
like Tinker or something I don't know
yeah I mean I mean it's possible but the
thing is like there's I don't I mean is
there anyone from you know this era of
rogues that you know is truly missing I
can't think of someone where I'm like ah
yeah well I guess there's no electro
opposite or the Rhino there was an
amazing friends right yeah
that's I'm just saying like I mean like
it's a yeah it's not like they're coming
at the expense of some like you know I
mean we even get a magneto episode which
is kind of cool too but yeah I mean you
know you always got to wonder are they
just trying to see like you know they
can hit on something I think also you
know there might also be without having
the creator's on and we can't you know
we can't verify but it's like I'm sure
there's some fun if you're working on
this on a Spiderman property like oh I
want to be able to create the next
spider-man villain you know what I mean
like this is a character I mean even
though it hadn't been done yet but a lot
of people wanting to do like kind of
like the Harley Quinn or x-23 thing is
like I want to contribute a character
that you know will eventually be brought
into the comics that could also be an
explanation I mean that's like what
happened was like Batgirl in the 60s
Batman show
and I'm not mistaken yeah well we're all
just dying for a sidewinder issue of
Amazing Spiderman it's coming oh boy I'd
love a whole action figure that guy
dance slot dance I could probably
deliver it dance Oh careful what you ask
for okay yeah a hundred percent so like
the last thing to really talk about here
is Peter's love life I mean it's it's
not that flesh out but it's more than it
was in the 60s and um you know they went
with Betty here which I think you know
as far as I can tell is this the only
one where Betty is presented as his love
in an animated show well was she out
then I'm totally forgetting yeah yeah
yeah female counterpart I guess for that
one cuz like the others I don't think
the other thing like existed yet maybe
yeah but it's but it's odd to me that
like so she's there but like MJ and Gwen
or not and okay I can understand maybe
not wanting to bring Gwen and because
then like you know how do you explain
that she's dead in the comics but no MJ
and if you want to say well MJ was
basically written out by this point but
Betty Brant was like married to Ned
Leeds and like Peter being with her it
was like having an affair in the comics
at this point so like I like
and again like they're dating but it's
not like I I never get the sense that
they they're this like truly like like
long-standing relationship it's kind of
more of just a fling and I don't know
like I'm I'm a sucker for Peter having a
love life whether I mean you know it's
it's never going good for him but like I
feel I want something more than this
okay with a couple of places like there
was the whole there was a black hat
episode where she asked him to go out on
a date and he takes Betty Brant to like
some live show but he has to sneak out
as spider-man because he's also the
guest on this show so he's like hold on
I'll be right back I just gotta go to
the bathroom and spider-man swings and
she's like that Peters missing it this
is so cool and like by the end of that
episode she's so mad at him for bailing
that she ends up
like kind of jokingly taking Jonah out
for a date while while Peter is like
dammit I can't do both and like I kind
of appreciated that it it ended with him
not having a win necessarily like you
know he caught the black cat he beat the
bad guy and you know save the day is
spider-man but then he gets back into
Peter Parker outfit and then just gets
kind of like a little bit of a middle
finger and that's just like like I said
that feels a the very own brand for the
character you know at least for the
early stuff before the actual
relationships started you know going on
for longer than that kind of scenario
well very cool we're gonna move on and
each of us is gonna share an episode
that we recommend or think is special in
some way so we're gonna go in order that
they were released so that makes you up
first
Xavier you're talking about an episode
you tell us of which one you chose I
chose the Sandman is coming I actually
thought that episode was just it
impressed me particularly because I felt
like it had like everything that I
specifically looked for in spider-man
stories like I like you know the the
mechanics of having a deal with costume
repair and like that kind of thing so it
was kind of cool how his costume gets
all shredded like his mask gets pulled
off by Sandman and he has to go swinging
around for a little while until he can
get back home to fix it and put on
another one I like the amount of near
misses with his secret identity because
Aunt May accidentally almost sees the
the costume in his closet a handful of
times there was also like you know Peter
Parker gets screwed over by spider-man
saving the day kind of thing where he
gets reported to his school by like some
some girl he was on like a like an
assignment with four kind of bailing out
as soon as Sandman showed up and he has
to go explain that before he ends up
getting like kicked out of school and
now there's like this ticking clock
element of he has to catch Sandman and
stop stop him you know his like crime
spree but also go clear like the board
at a school and then I just also really
loved that scene
where he gets tied to the train tracks
and like there's that little exchange
where Jonah is trying to take pictures
of him you know like tied up looking
like an idiot and I thought like all of
the dialogue in that scene just felt
very on brand for both characters like
they both just sound like spider-man and
Jonah even like a modern comic and like
the little witty retorts and sarcastic
remarks just like we're really cool to
me like the and then also at the end of
it I just love how he you know you're
laughing at that that picture for that
one image of him on the train tracks
doing that weird sexy pose as a joke but
uh then also the episode ends with one
of like one of my other favorite
spider-man things that I think doesn't
get enough appreciate like certain
adaptations is like he outsmarts the
villain and just kind of like he doesn't
necessarily need to brute-force it to
beat them he just comes up with a way to
let them beat themselves centrally by
leading Sandman through like a car wash
and then to a construction site where he
gets you know covered and like wet
cement and then the combination of the
two basically turns him into a statue
that that just kind of reminded me of
stories like nothing stops the
juggernaut or like you know that had
early kind of stuff where he's always
coming up with a really clever and sly
way to beat them without actually having
punched punch his way out so yeah just I
like that episode I feel like it's it's
a good episode to just represent the
whole show is just like it has a little
bit of everything
and samma is such a good villain to have
him outsmart in that way because
otherwise Sam and he's kind of you know
punching above his weight and trying to
apprehend him so like he always has to
kind of extract creative there so yeah
mark what about you what episode did you
choose yeah well you know obviously Dan
as we talked about in season 3 I'm a big
apologist for more granted I'm gonna
pick a team-up episode
I picked a peso de team which is the
capture of Captain America I'm also kind
of a sucker for a cap story but like
part of the reason why I like this
beyond the fact that I thought it was
kind of a really good functional team-up
premise was the fact that you know we're
we're kind of playing with some classic
Spidey predicaments and that you know
he's basically trying to kind of prove
himself to cap by by saving him from
this this plot from the Red Skull from
being captured and of course you know do
the Spidey's kind of inadvertent
incompetence cap gets captured anyway so
then like you know now that cap has been
captured Peter has to kind of think of a
way to both redeem himself but also like
not get his his idol killed you know we
have some you know I guess proto amazing
spider-man 700 action going on here with
the Red Skull trying to swap minds with
Captain America that you know that's the
kind of the master plot here where he's
gonna put you know Captain in red skulls
body so you know combining or we're
excuse me the other way around putting
red skulls mine and Kasbah so basically
combining the brilliance of the red
skull with caps you know immortal
physique physicality but but Spidey of
course does find a way to kind of save
the day clumsily Allah another one of my
favorite controversial moments of
spider-man history kind of throwing
himself onto the the container to free
the Avengers against Thanos in Marvel
two-in-one annual number two one of the
most essential issues of spider-man of
all time of course of course changed my
mind
anyway no so it's it's it's it's got
that classic the classic spider-man
elements of success you know kind of in
spite of himself after kind of setting
himself you know basically failing into
success and also it's just a fun team-up
episode and it just kind of felt
different in and unique especially in
the in the long line of all these doom
episodes I
I just like to you know like it was
probably of all the guest star episodes
although I'm probably gonna offend you
Dan
based on your next choice I felt it was
the best of all like the kind of the
guest starring episodes in terms of a
crossover I don't disagree with you I
love that Spiderman has to kind of like
dress up as Captain America to thwart
everyone and that that's fun
whenever Peter kind of has to assume the
mantle of somebody else I enjoyed that a
lot about this episode but yeah just a
lot of work elements but what's yours
Dan yeah you mentioned mine mine I mean
I chose after you so like you may have
grabbed my favorite but I actually
really like the return of kingpin it's
the you know the actually the first
kingpin episode I guess that he's
returning from another show or he's
returning to power this one has a
team-up with spider-man and Namor which
is not really a team up on that fond of
I mean I think about like the Denny
O'Neil run of spider-man where name
weren't him to teamed up which we talked
about on a previous episode but what I
like about this episode is the kind of
like psychological element of it is that
like kingpin is using all of his
resources to trick spider-man into like
the warding crime but it's like Thor
ting crime so that he can benefit off of
it and we kind of saw this in the
ultimate spider-man comic at one point
there was a whole arc about this where
it's you know Spiderman was kind of torn
between stopping crime and aiding the
kingpin and I like that I thought that
this show was being clever
it also features like fun kingpin
beating up a bunch of goons which which
is great I loved his training sequences
where he just like has men that whose
only job it is for him to pummel that's
a lot of fun and and I love it that's
happened before in the comics Bunch so
that was cool yeah and I was very
daredevil ish to Frank Miller derrida
yeah yeah and I love the kind of deep
cuts that appear in this episode there's
like a bunch of other rival gang Lords
and that's like hammerhead man Mountain
Marko makes an appearance
Silvermane and like really obscurely
Caesar Cicero
shows up from the lifeline tablet issues
and to me that's like they don't have
any speaking lines are just there in the
background and to me that suggests these
creators like really love the comic
books or at least they did their
homework get their homework
yeah and that means a lot to me I I
really appreciated that but yeah that's
my pick is the return of kingpin but
look if you want to talk about
spider-man we've got a special place for
you to do so mark why don't you tell us
about this oh boy yeah so hundreds of
listeners like you hang out in our
community of spider-man fans on the
slack The Amazing Spider slack community
is absolutely free to join and you can
jump into active conversations with
awesome people about collecting
conventions movies new comics all comics
and more yeah mark I'm there all the
time just this week we were talking
about how disturbing it is that Marvel
released a mary jane toy with an
interchangeable gwen stacy head and well
i mean i don't know how you feel about
that but it made for an interesting
conversation nevertheless so yeah just
follow the link in the description and
be sure to say hi let us know what you
thought of the episode if you join us
there and our amazing spider slack and
his amazing friends we're here to talk
about
will will be exclusively singing in this
portion of the show yeah so yeah we
talked a little bit about this mark tell
us a little bit more about the history
of this show right well it debuted again
September 12 1981 but this was on NBC
Saturday morning cartoon block so thus
far more exposure and it was 24 it was
it was just basically the same number of
episodes of spider-man 81 but they broke
it up into three seasons although
they're very oddly segmented seasons
like seasons one is episodes 1 through
13 and then season 2 is only 14 through
16 which were the three origin episodes
and then the final season which is
episode 17 before they brought in
Stanley Ashley to narrate portions of
the season and as you alluded to in the
intro Dan this was envisioned as a
competitor to ABC's Super Friends series
which was kind of the the DC Justice
League show so it basically runs 81
through 83 and then it ran if three
additional years on NBC as reruns before
showing up in that live-action or not
live-action that Marvel action block
with spider-man anyone I think the Hulk
animated series was part of that block
too so I mean you know kind of a similar
trajectory but like this one gained far
more traction and I think being on NBC
for essentially six years I probably
have a lot to do with the fact that it's
be you know far more remembered than the
other series mark you're a little bit
older than Xavier and myself
do you remember watching this on TV when
you were a kid or did you miss this yeah
100% I mean I was too I mean as as old
as I am I didn't see it in the original
run like 81 83 I mean I was I was too in
80 in 1983 but like I I definitely have
memories in like the mid 80s so figure
85 86 waking up on a Saturday morning
and watching this show so I I couldn't
tell you which episodes I saw back then
but I definitely I was a total Saturday
morning cartoon junkie as
a kid that age and this was part of that
that block of shows for sure Xavier when
did you first kind of like was it that
VHS tape that first expose you to this
yeah yeah because I it was a VHS tape
that was just like a block of a couple
episodes the one that I remember most
vividly was the x-men crossover but
eventually like they started airing
reruns of this on like I think I Disney
XD or something like there was a TV
channel that would start playing a
couple of old episodes every once in a
while and like I must have been like 10
or 11 around that time so I would
occasionally catch them on there and
like kind of you know see what the fuss
was all about because I know people were
still like even back then I knew people
would reference the show and talk about
it but I had only seen like a little bit
of it and for me it was all about that
VHS tape and I always remember being
like okay I know Iceman I know
spider-man but I have no idea who this
Firestar character is what's the deal
with Firestar yeah so basically it
sounds like the you know in terms of
friends to pair with spider-man they
wanted to do a Fire and Ice motif and
and obviously Johnny Storm would have
been the ideal choice I mean he was
literally like Spider man's best friend
of me from the comics but as we alluded
to earlier in the show there were some
rights issues hence her be the robot in
that Fantastic Four series which was you
know run by the same production company
so they decided instead to create an
original character Angelica Jones
Firestar to be the the the fire elements
of this show and so she was created
specifically for this cartoon but she
would eventually make her comics debut
in uncanny x-men number 193 in 1985 so
although I don't feel I'm not an X
reader and you know I'm not gonna pin it
on you Xavier despite your name but like
I don't feel like she's ever in
a bade miyan character an x-men right I
mean it's this always you know she's
kind of just popped up from time to time
right even in spite of my name I don't
really read x-men books I either I just
as far as I know about Firestar in the
comics this is that Bendis made lizallen
Firestar in the ultimate run that was a
bizarre choice but amazing friends arc
for a little while there in the ultimate
book that I thought was kind of neat
yeah they actually lived with Peter and
Aunt May just like in this series you
know and it becomes a bit of a flophouse
for young super-powered people but yeah
I mean I kind of like Firestar she's got
a lot of personality about her I mean
she carries with her a lot of like nasty
tropes that you know I think we wouldn't
see today obviously where everybody is
hitting on her constantly like the
design of the costume is neat Flash
Thompson you know one of the things I
like about this show if we're just
talking you know kind of broad
historical things it's like thank God
they added more songs to the musical
score I mean all of our favorites come
back but at least it's broader in its
scope this time around it's like there's
like four songs instead of two I'll take
it I'll take it
you know that brings up the question
like is this a sequel to the original
spider-man show you said earlier mark
that you felt like the originals that
1981 spider-man show is more of a sequel
to the 60s show than this was to the 81
show like where are those discrepancies
live for you there's a few I mean
talking specifically from the plot like
you know and there are there are other
people on the internet who have
theorized about this but like you know
one of the things if you like to point
out like is this a sequel is that a
companion show whatever if you look at
the Red Skull and Doctor Doom who both
show up in this I mean in inspire Man 81
those characters are are kind of left
for dead by the end of their their
appearances you know doom at the end of
his are
and then the Red Skull in that episode
with Captain America that we talked
about earlier and they show up here
pretty much alive and and unchecked
however it seems like magneto when he
shows up here kind of alludes to the
spider-man 81 episode that he shows up
in so I mean a little you know there's a
little bit of a inconsistency but just
in general like like these shows are
essentially concurrently produced shows
and like never at any point there's like
Spider Man kind of allude to his life
without Firestar and Iceman like hey I'm
also having adventures on my own guys
taking place before them yeah yeah it's
just kind of it's like they're very
independently staged and it just so
happens that they were released around
the same time with the same production
company with similar sounding scores and
animation styles but like yeah because
like Peter like both are if I'm not
mistaken it's pretty much the same
design across both shows like like I
think they might have used the same like
model sheets or whatever but like where
he lives - that may is different and may
I think has a design change like Jonah
doesn't necessarily have the same look
like everything for some reason that
he's like the only character I remember
being very like explicitly the same
across both shows everyone else has like
little - so while the voices are all
different even spider-man's voice Daniel
Bayesian yeah he white or different
recast he was the first couch so good
yeah I mean the only reason I like
Daniel Bayesian is because his his name
is so similar to mine that I get
mistaken for him in the spider-man
community every now and again but yeah I
mean that feels like a real step down
for for for me that the voice acting is
just not as good
oh for sure and like yeah forgot his
name the guy who plays Fred and
scooby-doo a lot and his Iceman in this
either chime in please help me remember
his name I don't I don't know it you're
good with names yeah I know I didn't I
don't have it but okay this is great
guys talk amongst yourselves while I
search okay but anyway yeah a lot of the
characters are very clearly just that
same voice like Flash Thompson and
shocker and Frank wells like a lot of
random Frank Welker that's what I feel
like an idiot for now remembering that
like he's still working today he's so
prolific but yeah it was it became
distracting how many reused voices there
were I think even at some point during
that x-men crossover episode had the
same voice of spider-man and like
whoever voiced like Nightcrawler sounded
like three other characters like they
really didn't have a big cast to work
with and it's it because it kind of
takes you out of the moment a little one
two characters sound exactly the same
and are talking to each other quite get
what they were going for with Wolverine
and his voice is he is he trying to be
like gambit I don't get it it's two
different cartoons around that time
where Wolverine was Australian for no
reason because there's also the pilot
episode of that x-men show that never
took off Pryde of the x-men he was
Australian and that too
I don't know what the connection is
there maybe we should look into that
sometime okay you guys are right in
Canadian and Australian I mean basically
and you guys are save life the same
hemisphere
you guys are like floating around them
whatever you guys are floating around
the bigger point which is that like the
cached in this show was enormous
compared to the spider-man 81 show
because every show was like 20 new cast
members because of how broad this show
gets into the Marvel Universe and let's
just talk about our general thoughts on
the show and I'll just get
right to it which is like I think the
show is insane I think it is completely
bonkers you're stealing my word dad cuz
bonkers this is the word that keeps
coming back to me this is this show is
totally nuts it makes no sense it's like
I mean like as much as comics don't make
sense like I I literally like hurt
myself trying to actually do the mental
gymnastics it takes for me to kind of
figure many elements of the show out but
I mean maybe I'm just being unfair to it
this feels like a lot more superhero
cartoons around the time well as 81 felt
much like an add up like just a direct
adaptation here's you know here's what
spider-man is this is just like those
types of shows where it's like it's
character and like a little bit of their
their lore thrown in but then just a lot
of crazy other stuff that they shouldn't
be doing like falling in love with space
aliens and time-traveling and whatever
like it's it's just off the wall because
I think maybe they thought that that
would be more toy attic you could get
more you could get more stuff to turn
into like products that way if you
weren't just directly going for
spider-man asked stories yeah and then
it also just placed into the fact I mean
like as a Saturday morning cartoon I
mean like you kind of like have to be
over-the-top I mean think about like all
the other shows that were on at this
time I mean like it's I think a
straight-up superhero adaptation for the
80s which is like in any of these
cartoon would not work like this I mean
this is like yeah it's fanciful it's
crazy you know why Herman eighty one
kind of proved to us because that it
didn't catch on like it did it did the
job that we were looking for as fans of
the character but like yeah it wasn't
that thing that was going to catch on
and become like a sensation like they
were open for it
yeah because I feel like the holes that
we see in it and like the the the
logical fallacies that we see in it
we're only seeing it because our our
point of comparison are the comics but
if like you're just some kid coming to
this fresh being like oh man like
spider-man it's awesome I love Ice Man
it's awesome I love these things like
they're you know again you're they're
not carrying that like those kids are
just coming off of like Johnny Kao
yeah yeah like like the fact that they
have this secret lair that like kind of
turns inside and outside in Aunt May's
house like most like oh boy I don't know
for sure cuz I never had it because I
grew up away after the show but I
absolutely could see that being like one
of those like playset gimmick things or
it's like oh look it's there you know
they're goofy college student apartment
but you pull this lever and suddenly
everything flips around and then like
it's missing bat-poles almost as how
close it is to something like that yeah
definitely Batman asked for sure and and
you know again like we're sitting here
like arguing about it because like oh
that would in the comics like Peter
would never be able to hide something
thats afford it that's like that's
another thing is because in the episode
I wanted to talk about there's an intro
from Stanley going we heard your we've
been hearing your questions we want to
answer this for you how could all these
college students who rarely have money
afford all of this high-tech equipment
well we're gonna answer your question
for you like I think people even back
then we're starting to question it a
little bit for them to have to write
that into the narration right right I I
could see that being like a big fan mail
like contention thing like how the
hell's all this coming together maybe
this was just like Stanley like watching
the cartoon for the first time and being
like wait what happened
maybe you just maybe used some executive
meddling on his part and he actually
kind of tried to improve the show which
I honestly don't have a problem with cuz
you know I think his input was valuable
I feel like the contemporary for this
show in terms of modern shows to compare
it to is probably the ultimate
spider-man cartoon it feels like often
times that like this show is more
interested in exploring the rest of the
Marvel Universe through the eyes of
spider-man like we get very little of
Peter Parker's life in this other than
handling how he hides all this from Aunt
which is just by tugging on a statue but
you know there are full episodes where
like spider-man does almost next to
nothing like there's one with Thor where
he's trapped inside of like a gem and
that's it you know and it's a Thor story
where Thor is fighting a cloned Thor
which is actually Loki you know it's got
that kind of like Marvel team-up crazy
plots from the comics but in terms of
cartoon shows it really feels like that
ultimate spider-man show yeah and yet
the origin episode for Peter because
they do they do three different origin
episodes we'll talk a little bit more
about one of them in a bit but like the
Peter one is just well I mean like 90
like literally amazing fantasy 15 I mean
it's just like pay almost notice I think
that episode had like a higher budget
than a lot of the other ones because
something about it just looks a lot more
modern and professional like it'd look
more like the 90s cartoon there was like
actual shading on the sella animation
the backgrounds were more detailed and
had like a sort of grit to them like it
wasn't as bright and poppy and colorful
like it had sort of a visual style that
for some reason that episode just
doesn't look like a lot of the other
ones I remember yeah he's just totally
jarring for me considering how
off-the-wall everything else about the
show is that they do this you know this
origin episode for Peter and you're like
oh wow this is like like straight
straight out of the comics that's that's
impressive kind of what it felt like
with the sixties cartoon is just like
here's a lot of you know crazy random
weird whatever we can come up with like
reused animation from other shows even
in some cases and then here's in Smid
they're like season 2 openers here's
just a just a direct adaptation of the
origin just in case you didn't know what
it was and like between the two of them
I prefer the mayonnaise and Friends
version actually because I also like
that they kind of frame like after
around it yeah but now here's the here's
a question here's another like logical
question I have so contractually how do
things actually work with Iceman and
Firestar in spider-man because like they
also established in the show that Iceman
and Firestar are also
x-men but it's like they are they are
basically never part of the X team in
this show other than what the episodes
we're x-men during the episode where
they get together she makes like a
Punnett about it so like doesn't see and
then like and they're living with Peter
full-time so yeah I just I don't know
like it didn't fully click for me that
like that they were truly fully divorced
cause like I don't know I mean it just
seemed weird to me yeah no I agree like
they they say X x-men like they're not
part of them anymore but they still hang
out with them constantly you know I
don't know I haven't I didn't watch the
entirety of the show just like--all I
just kind of cherry picked episodes that
seemed interesting just because of time
constraints but like I don't think at
any point I ever saw them explained
necessarily why they left the x-men or
what was going on with that
so yeah it's never explained yes um one
of the things that always bothers me
about the show is like this really weird
love triangle that's going on where
Peter and and Bobby are kind of
competing for fire stars affection and
Firestar has like her own kind of sex
life that she's got going on where she's
dating other men and making them jealous
at one point she dates Dracula but you
know like you like you do but like it's
always been very scary to me and putting
on a front I kind of informs a lot of
older stuff about Iceman like in the the
x-men legends game he says flirty things
about girls every 10 seconds and it's
like you're trying too hard Bobby yeah
and like I mean I also hate to say it
too but I feel like in the especially in
the first few episodes like Angelica
definitely comes across this and got it
like this de saying the term makes me
kind of want to cringe but like there's
like different MarySue qualities to her
in terms of like like green that first
episode that green common one it's like
you know Bobby and Peter are basically
getting you know into
all sorts of troubling and it's like
well here comes Angelica they just solve
all the problems and it's like whoa but
like I feel like they do kind of temper
that as the show goes on I mean she gets
into her own issues where she needs to
be bailed out and they kind of all I
mean if anything Peter kind of
experiment kind of comes out as like the
alpha of the group but for the most part
I feel like they all kind of play off
each other which which is technically a
good thing I would say in terms of like
a team-up show you do want to see them
all kind of working together and and and
aiding each other for the most part we
have to talk about fire stars pet miss
lion who is a key member of the cast and
defeats supervillains in an episode or
two like so Firestar has a pet dog miss
lion and it must that must have been an
executive note somewhere that said we
need an animal or a dog at the heart of
this show yeah that was a ripoff of
wondered it was a wonder dog I think
from Superfriends I mean this was like
you know in terms of like the the
Saturday morning superhero cartoon wars
apparently miss lion is like a
straight-up
ape of wonder dog I understand that that
whole archetype you could even kind of
trace back to like scooby-doo Fame
because there was a lot of hanna-barbera
like kind of knockoffs trying to get in
on that that Fame so a group of
teenagers with dog sidekick you know and
it just seems very derivative of a lot
of things in the comic in spider-verse
when we visit the amazing friends
universe they're all killed all of these
characters are killed officially by Dan
Slott except for Miss lion who stands
over their dead bodies and howls because
that's the kind of good Saturday morning
fun that you want
yes canonically all these characters are
dead you don't have the vocabulary to
describe the murder I've just done
because this is a universe where death
doesn't exist
no definitely not I'm glad that they
eventually went back and then said like
just to kind of quell the the anger is
that okay all of those were like not
the actual universe of the cartoons just
one adjacent are close enough the actual
amazing spider-man or amazing friends
and spider-man unlimited all those guys
are still around somewhere so then the
other thing I thought was kind of weird
with this show Dan was like we got like
far less Jonah right am i am i miss
remembering this I mean I just bear I
just binge tit so maybe I'm maybe the
shows are blurring together but I don't
feel it we got a lot of Jonah I don't
think we got any Betty all right but
like the bugle itself I mean it's it
it's a character but like very it's not
obviously as prominent as what we saw in
spider-man 81 which I thought was a
little unfortunate yeah he only shows up
in one episode which is this one
spider-man unmasked with Sandman and you
know Sandman finds out Peters identity
and kind of uses it to wreak havoc on
him and and that incorporates Jonah but
yeah it's really weird he just
disappears like it's like they got an
existing executive note that says nobody
likes Joni for how they got together he
has like a brief little thing in that
where he's like hey I got the pictures
of spider-man and Jonah's like no people
want pictures of Firestar and Iceman
that's right I remember yeah weird that
his mustache was like the color of like
his temples like it was white instead of
black in it yeah seems like a coloring
error I noticed that too
yeah I mean it's like they like I said
they got like in a note that said nobody
likes Jonah so get rid of him and that's
what happened I guess yeah I like him
too yeah apparently like Marc Webb an
amazing spider-man movies I guess like
maybe it's the same production maybe
Stan spiked it just because he wanted to
do the voice of him for the amazing
spider-man movies is that Jay jonah
Jameson is also played by JK Simmons in
there you just don't get to see him make
sense to me make sense to me so let's
talk about some of our favorite or
notable episodes
from this run I I'm gonna start it off
because we're gonna go sequentially and
I chose to so I'm cheating but yeah I'm
just gonna do it because like they're
both so weird I thought that like I have
to talk about how weird these episodes
are because frankly mark I'm surprised
you didn't choose one of these episodes
so the first one I'm talking about is
the episode 3 which is the fantastic mr.
frump and this I'll talk briefly but so
there it's like it's a Doctor Doom
spider-man story and one of the few from
amazing friends maybe they felt like
they overused him in the spider-man show
where Doctor Doom gets this like amulet
that gives him basically the power of
like the Infinity stones and he like
just gets it knocked out of his hands
because of course if you have something
that powerful it's easy to lose and it
goes to this random guy that used to
work with like Aunt May named mr. frump
and he's this like another balding
character so I'm destined to talk about
this and he gets the powers of God
essentially and he's just this like
persnickety old man and he uses it to
basically like transform the city into
like a wonderland he like has these kids
that are bullying him and he like
basically turns the kids into animals
and slaves which is interesting and he
turns like like he can summon animals
and creatures out of nowhere there's a
famous moment where he summons a cat for
himself and he says I'll call him Mabel
and then it cuts to commercials like
that was a big cliffhanger like oh what
was he gonna name the cat I'll call it
Mabel so there you go and eventually it
turns into this like battle in this big
arena in like I don't know like beyond
the beyonders realm and spider-man it's
like fighting against like a giant
tentacle monster like something straight
out of spider-man hooky it's like so
weird you're like what is this show and
I remember watching this and IIIi will
admit
I loved the spider-man 1981 show but in
terms of binging this show is way better
because I never knew where it was going
each of these episodes feels like it was
just a team of improv comedians just
making stuff up from second to second
it's so strange so that's episode three
the fantastic mr. fring a recurring
structure for the episodes yeah it's
just all over the place and you never
know like minute to minute what bizarre
new kind of like thing they're gonna
throw out there for you to digest so
that's the fantastic mr. strums and
speaking of bizarre what's your other
episode is of course it's swarm favorite
favorite of our show so so this one he's
not actually a Nazi skeleton in this one
he's just like a meteorite crash Lanza's
and radioactive yeah I guess that's true
but he's technically is Red Skull and
Nazi yeah right there you go
inside joke but yes these bees come and
they are formed into swarm who at first
seems to only be able to say his name
and he flies across the farmlands
shouting swarm at people and in this he
has a very unique ability he can
transform human beings into like be
human hybrids that he controls including
Aunt May who spouts antennae and grows B
eyes and he of course likes warm is want
to do summons a giant beehive in the
middle of like the countryside and it's
up to spider-man and his spider friends
to pretend that there be people and go
into the hive and grab the meteor and
destroy the radioactive bees that are
swarm and to me the highlight of the
episode is them disguising themselves
as bees Iceman grows I swings out of his
back and spider-man puts fake be eyes
over his already insect eyes so it's
like if you were wearing glasses you put
on another aware of glasses yeah it's
very odd so that is the swarm episode
and you know if you're looking just for
weird episodes to check out on Disney
Plus like that's episode three and five
you really can't go wrong they are every
minute something stranger and stranger
is happening so those are my picks
because that's the love I got of the
show is just where is it going next so
mark the episode you're gonna talk we've
kind of talked about a little bit before
tell us about which one you chose this
one's far less weird
I picked a fire star is born' which I
guess is technically from season two
episode three it's one of the the origin
shows that I alluded to earlier part of
the reason why I like this so much when
I was watching it for the first time the
other day I was like oh man this is like
og Spidey versus juggernaut of course
the x-factor into the storyline were of
course in the comics you know spider-man
was on his own but like you know it's
it's it's very similar in structure to
that Roger stern story in that you know
Spidey is literally throwing everything
he can although he even throws cement at
him and it's like a cement pit at him
and he gets out of that so take that
Roger stern you thought that would be
what foiled him but beyond that we get
fire stars origin and while it is very I
feel Stephen King carry esque in terms
of like you know trying to bully the
girl in high school with with the with
the weird powers it's a pretty solid
origin although like I feel like they're
setting it up to be far more tragic than
it turns out to be I mean it's like
basically like there's this well in high
school who's just like utterly bullying
the crap out of Angelica and you know
rather than like basically like pushing
her into full-out outcast territory
which would explain how she joined up
with the x-men it's like you know she
still finds a way to kind of
Angelica still finds a way to kind of
come out on top and absolve her name and
then she just joints the x-men anyway so
like that's a bit of a cheat to me I
mean like I feel like if this wasn't a
Saturday morning like kids cartoon they
probably would have gotten the darker
route and you know like forced her out
in kind of a more sinister way but
beyond that like we get a cool x-men
team up we get a good juggernaut
spider-man fight here we got Australian
Wolverine which I mean like you can't
get better than that clearly you get
storm and then like finally like them
like ah glean another woman in this show
besides Angelica which is kind of
refreshing I guess that you know it's
Equal Opportunity chauvinism so there
you go I mean like like to me and a pun
on you know a famous movie so so what's
better than that fire star is born' my
recommendation
so apparently the stream just went down
because of policy violations so Xavier
you were right they do not like a
showing this this particular episode oh
really
yes apparently you get shut down and
like all places I don't know let's go
let's check really quickly here sorry if
anybody's watching this we're gonna
we're gonna go see what's going on with
the stream what about the people who are
seeing the stream on my channel yeah I
don't know let's see I don't know if
anybody has said that yes it says live
now let me see okay well well we'll keep
going then and we'll figure it out so so
that's not the the juggernaut episode
Xavier do you want to quickly talk about
the one that I liked was um just the
origin of the spider-friends because
like I don't know a lot of the weirder
elements of the show don't kinda kind of
gel with me as well like I don't really
like it in the ironic sense as much or
the like just seeing out we're to get I
was kind of looking for more stuff from
like 81 spider
and so the fact that this about Mary
Peter Parker oriented like he was kind
of the main character and you know they
took like a really heavy backseat like
sure they're introduced and team up with
him but they don't feel necessarily like
they're kind of impeding on on the
spider-man Miss of this episode or like
kind of imposing and so really
appreciate that like you know the
villain is is the beetle okay hang on
actually just one second it's down on
both of ours now it actually looks like
on YouTube as well all right well I
apologize Xavier do you want to just
finish it up and then we'll put a stop
yeah I suppose so that sucks a little
worried about that
yeah I've you were right you were right
look at that it's still going on
Facebook yeah
we're not going to be able to get it
back up so we'll just finish up the for
the recording and then I'll edit these
out I'll edit these out and send a
different version to everybody okay okay
so finish off I guess saying what you
were saying and we'll figure it out it's
weird because it's yeah that particular
episode I just liked how I don't know it
just reminded me the most of the 81 show
and I was kind of just looking for more
of that since I like that one a lot and
all of the weird like other superhero
stuff in the universe like Mad Men or
Iron Man's inclusion they all just felt
very toned down and not intrusive so
like you know if you're looking for an
episode that's like kind of not as
bizarre as all the rest of them and like
feels pretty typical of spider-man stuff
I think that one's probably the one to
go with yeah it's a great choice
a lot of fun too and even though the
Beatles in a typical villain it's it's
it's neat to see like you know the kind
of heavy character oriented scripting
that the show I think leaned far away
from can I take the precedence here yeah
yeah
Xavier do you want to take up do you
want to take a pause by starscream take
a pause I don't know I yeah I don't I
don't know if you have like how are
having anxiety about it but it is down
so I just want to finish up whichever
you guys want to do I guess let's just
finish up and then we'll figure it out
I'm sorry Xavier I feel bad about this
that's no problem it's I mean for good
reason yeah I know you were right I mean
I've done enough videos with copyrighted
footage to know that uh YouTube is very
fun very kind of bratty about what it
wants to do you know say is okay and
what isn't for that kind of thing yeah
alright well let's finish up sorry there
are people probably watching and other
streams are like what the hell is
happening right now so sorry everybody
that's watching okay well let's let's
thank you for it's a great choice of an
episode Xavier and and a lot of fun so
you know guys I know we're down right
now but if you find the show
entertaining and valuable please
consider supporting us recommend amazing
spider talk to a friend and if you're
able become a member on patreon we can
only bring you this content with the
support of our patreon members and we
owe the show's success to every single
one of them we are constantly making
exclusive content for our members this
week it's a special podcast review of
Amazing Spider Man vol 5 number 43
Marvel comics are back baby
also Dan and I are hosting interactive
Members Only live streams as well you
know comic release up again the
distribution chain gets sorted out and
you can pick up your copious poles
you'll hear our patreon exclusive review
podcast on every new issue of Amazing
Spiderman the same we
that it comes out and if you contribute
$10 a month you gain access to exclusive
artwork from famous spider-man artists
commissioned exclusively for our members
this season will be mailing out a print
of nothing can stop the juggernaut drawn
by official Marvel artist max V Mora in
colors and inks plus every episode we
release a new episode specific desktop
background created for us by artist Nick
cagnetti for our patrons to enjoy we
know this is a hard time for everybody
so we appreciate anyone who supports the
show just by listening and sharing but
if you do have the means please join us
on patreon to support our continued
existence of our show just follow the
link in the description and thank you to
all the members who already make this
show possible by the last and it is that
time time for all good things to come to
an end so we want to say thank you to
you the listeners and viewers for tuning
in to the episodes of The Amazing Spider
talk of course thanks to you Xavier
Mendoza for stopping by and hanging out
with us and talking about these these
cool cartoons of course it was it was a
good time you know little technical
glitches aside I had a great time and it
was it was nice talking to you guys so
where can we find you on YouTube Xavier
got just I mean if you just look up
spider-man videogames I'll probably be
one of the first results and again if
the kind of thing that I make over there
is game reviews refuse of like animated
shows usually based around like comics
and it's the occasional cosplay tutorial
if any of that sounds interesting then
go go gimme a look but uh right for
right now I'm doing a lot more cartoon
based stuff kind of like this so I'm
actually gonna review both the 81 show
and amazing friends and more of it I can
kind of script out my thoughts a little
bit more and you know write probably
some funnier jokes towards those and
that'll be coming out in the next couple
of months and you've got a great a bunch
of videos like one about dance lots run
on comics that I like maybe a little
controversial but I thought really made
an excellent point about you know
storytelling in calm
and stuff and comparing his run to Nick
Spencer's and you know if you're if
you're a listener of ours I know you'll
really dig that episode of your show oh
yes it's how Nick Nick Spencer redeemed
spider-man I wrote a read around the
time that uh that art first started
because I was really digging what they
were doing with it at the time yeah it's
really great so thanks again
Xavier yeah it was a lot of fun having
you on and yeah so this episode
obviously was edited by Rick coast with
production support from Annie Meyer's
our artwork comes handcrafted by artist
Ron friend Sal boosts an array some xur
and Nick cagnetti and our theme songs
were produced by Ryland Bojack and
spider-man and our animated introduction
what's created by Josh Sutton of the
panels to pixels YouTube show it's up
again yeah it's it's up on my channel at
least well there you go welcome back
everybody
so live streaming everybody welcome
we got the strike is because we stopped
showing the footage from episode yeah I
guess that's it so don't show footage
from amazing friends everybody but it's
at we're coming to the end of the show
where we're thanking Xavier for coming
on which you know we're want to do but
we're going to talk about like what's
coming up next well yeah actually I
can't wait for our next episode because
you know we're gonna be joined by
another special guest this time it's
spider-man editor Danny finger auth and
Danny is going to be joining us to talk
about all the superstar artists who work
on the spider-man books across this time
period of the late 70s and early 80s who
would go on to become more legendary in
the industry people like frank miller
john romita jr. and many more so it's
gonna be a really fun episode as we talk
about like a bunch of really awesome
artists with a famous spider-man editor
so you know join us I think it's gonna
be a lot of fun yeah so if you missed
out
our live stream or even miss out on the
missing five minutes of our live stream
tonight be sure to check in on us in two
weeks and don't forget as soon as the
show ends the conversation continues
with our audience on YouTube don't worry
this is still a podcast that will always
remain consistent just like how we end
the show
so until Mortimer jameson becomes the
Daily Bugle zli refer what is our motto
Xavier with great podcast there must
also come um ellipses The Amazing Spider
Talk and that's the end of the show
everybody thanks for hanging around
despite all the technical glitches we're
gonna be answering some of your
questions so head on over to our chat
and ask questions of any of us about the
show about spider-man will answer like
two or three of them before we move on
to our patreon exclusive content so
thank you for tuning in this was a lot
of fun let's get some questions going
here let's see mmm questions questions
questions just waiting just wait
actually I'm sure that yeah mark do you
have any questions for Xavier Xavier do
you have a favorite run of spider-man
comics just a big fan of everything in
the age I I don't know this is like an
unpopular opinion but I kind of liked
the fact that the creative team kept
changing from like every couple of
issues so that I was always keeping it
kind of it's like new and unique and
Fred we're talking just like a single
writer and either Paul Jenkins or Vince
key you know yeah - a few little
blemishes on the gate sure sure we're
having some technical issues here with
Godzilla
our xavier z' a video image here but
yeah looks like there's something weird
going on boy we were doing so good for
such a long time and now it's like crazy
town there's always so so we can still
hear you so that's fine so so you like
the eighties show that's our eighties
series that's the one of a Amazing
Spiderman of love yeah it's like comics
ye yeah every era is probably just the
dull eighty just kind of like stretch of
books um like post women Stacy do I feel
like is like just a whole stretch is
just all good stuff in my opinion yeah
agreed agreed agreed
somebody's asking Xavier are there any
comics that you collect that I collect
I've been collecting the Donnie Kate's
and I'm run I have a lot of issues of
ultimate spider-man like that as much as
I used to but I still have them I try to
collect all of the Garth s run of
Punisher max because that's one of my
favorites then lately I've just been
getting a collection a bear bursting
storyline of spider-man and because my
friend from Florida keeps finding them
and then MIT telling them to me so
trouble both on hardcover and individual
issues and I have the power pack issue
like in mind something weird he sends it
to me so I guess I just have all the the
ones that everyone wants to forget about
- the power pack issue I I searched for
that for years and I would go to
conventions and be like do you have this
issue and peopled be like what are you
talking about and you know I would
explain the whole life
yeah I have one too but it took me a
long time to actually find one looking
funny I mean it didn't cost me much it's
just one of those things it's like who's
holding on to this you know it's such a
strange yeah issue but yeah so yeah
somebody's Tim burns is asking I noticed
the odd way they pronounced kazar in the
Craven episode in the 1981 show since
comics are a print medium are there any
other things you've seen like that when
trans translating from print to TV and
you guys think of anything where it's
like suddenly they're botching the name
this this 90s cartoon had no idea how to
pronounce symbiotes yeah
the symbiotic if you watch the trailer
yeah like fix that I don't know if like
a yard or something but she's yeah it's
really really strange okay let's get one
more question and then we'll figure out
what's going on with exactly there's
crazy video stuff if you three could
come up with a better title for venom 2
which is venom was it let there be
carnage what would it be like unique
movie because the if they called it
maximum carnage that would just be
confusing is it I would be like people
could go comic the game of the movie
making storylines or naming movies after
storylines they only are like vaguely
related to like Civil War or or infinity
war I liked like a special unique name
so it's you don't have to figure it out
it's just
or even angel I be down for venom tea
time with carnage that sounds good to me
I would buy yeah okay great so before
our tech completely crashes thank you
guys for tuning in if you want to join
us for more of these shows check out the
Amazing Spider Talk channel and the
Godzilla Mendoza YouTube channel
hopefully next time we do one of these
Xavier we were doing so good for so long
but maybe we flew too close to the Sun
yeah I see like my camera seems to be
just like flickering different colors
now I don't even know what's going on
with that we'll do it live how they have
a good night everybody
you know stay safe and all that around
everyone
[Music]
to be in 1962 Wednesday afternoon valve
injurious river
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]